Et si on faisait un peu de tourisme local aujourd’hui?
Alors, pas trop, parce que moi tu sais,
la campagne, les animaux bizarres...
j’suis pas très chaud.
Moi je connais déjà très bien la région,
mais ça dépend,
peut-être que Valentine a une idée précise.
Tu proposes quoi ?
Et si on allait à ITER!
- I-quoi ?"
- ITER, tu sais le machin nucléaire là.
Mais attends,
ça se visite pas ITER Valentine.
On est influenceurs on peut tout visiter.
Désolé, mais sans moi.
Marie ?
Moi j’irai ou tu iras Valentine.
Gilles, t’es sûr tu viens pas?
Vous connaissez le LHC ?
Le plus grand accélérateur de particules au monde,
qui s'étend sous la France, la Suisse et l'Italie ?
Eh bien ça tombe bien puisque je me situe pas du tout là, mais
dans un autre laboratoire géant de physique nucléaire dans le sud de la Fronce,
cocorico peuchère.
Qui est localisé ni à Cataracte ni à l'arrache
mais à Cadarache, dans les Bouches du Rhône.
Le but de ce lieu, ce n'est pas de découvrir de nouvelles particules élémentaires
comme le muon, le bison ou le poltron.
Nenni.
Il s'agit d'étudier la faisabilité d'un réacteur à fusion nucléaire.
Et oui, j'ai bien dit fusion et non pas fission
comme la plupart des réacteurs qu’on connaît,
comme ceux de Marcoule, Tricastin ou Flamanville.
Réacteur à fusion ou à fission,
y'a qu'un mot qui change mais ça change tout.
Un peu comme pied de porte et pied de poule.
Ou bien terre plein et terre brûlée.
Au vent.
Des landes de pierres...
Jusqu'à maintenant en France,
on utilise l'énergie nucléaire de fussoir – de fission.
Ça consiste à envoyer une pichenette
dans la tête d'un atome radioactif fissile.
Imaginez un prof de géologie ultra vénère
parce qu'il sort d'une réunion syndicale de profs
et que tous les espoirs qu'il avait en son
ministre de l'Education viennent de s'envoler.
Déjà, il est pas zen zen.
Quand soudain,
alors qu'il écrivait l'échelle de dureté des minéraux au tableau,
Monsieur Faille se prend un tir de sarbacane dans la tête.
Et là, ni une ni deux ni cinq, il explose.
Il va engueuler l'élève un peu trop téméraire.
Ergo, il émet de l'énergie.
Ce faisant, Monsieur Faille va se diviser
en deux messieurs plus légers et plus stables,
que nous appellerons Stéphane et Cher.
Mais Stéphane et Cher sont eux mêmes vénères,
c'est- à-dire radioactifs,
et ils vont se calmer en gueulant un bon coup
et en balançant une craie sur un pauvre élève qui n’a rien demandé.
Eh ben c'est la même chose dans notre centrale à fission.
On envoie un neutron sur un atome d'uranium fissile.
Lequel fissionne pour donner :
deux atomes plus légers, une poignée de neutrons et de l'énergie.
Et ces atomes plus légers peuvent se désintégrer
en dégageant aussi de l’énergie.
Si il y a d’autres Messieurs Faille,
c'est-à-dire des atomes fissiles,
dans les parages et qu’ils
se prennent un neutron dans la mouille,
ils vont exploser à leur tour
et on va avoir une réaction en chaîne.
Là, on a deux stratégies.
Soit on met plein de Messieurs Faille dans une très petite pièce
pour qu’ils pètent tous dès qu’on en fait craquer un.
Soit on les espace et on capte les craies qui volent
pour que l’explosion d’un Monsieur Faille en fasse juste craquer un autre,
et on contrôle la réaction en chaîne pour produire de la chaleur et, derrière, de l’électricité.
C'est une centrale nucléaire à fission.
Alors pourquoi Fukushima ?
Le problème ce n’est pas les Messieurs Faille
parce qu’on les a séparés dès que ça a commencé à partir en cacahuète,
mais les Stéphane et Cher qui continuent de bolosser des élèves,
c'est-à-dire émettre de la chaleur.
Si personne ne calme l’ambiance,
toute la classe fait la révolution et paf,
explosion de vapeur d’eau ou d’hydrogène.
Bref, arrêter la réaction en chaîne ne suffit pas,
il faut évacuer la chaleur…
continuer d’arroser Stéphane et Cher à la lance à incendie
jusqu’à ce que la plupart d’entre eux aient fini leur caca nerveux.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'on doit garder un œil
et même deux sur le cœur d'un réacteur à fission,
parce qu'à tout moment il peut nous faire un petit
revival de Fukushima.
Bon, pas vraiment à tout moment, c'est surveillé c't'affaire en vrai.
Donc voilà pour la fission.
Alors qu'au contraire, la fusion c'est la réaction inverse.
On prend deux atomes d'hydrogène lourd,
le deutérium et le tritium.
Nos atomes,
que nous appellerons Dupond D et Dupont T,
ont respectivement un et deux neutrons en plus
dans leur noyau par rapport à l'hydrogène mainstream.
C'est pour ça qu'ils sont lourds.
Ca et parce qu'ils peuvent pas s'empêcher
de raconter l'intégrale des blagues de Bigard aux repas de famille.
Et donc, que fait-on ?
Eh bien, nos deux Dupont, on les cogne l'un contre l'autre
jusqu'à temps qu'ils deviennent siamois.
On appellera notre siamois Dupont He pour Helium.
*Voix aïgue*
Ca n’a vraiment plus aucun sens.
Eh oui, parce que fusionner du deutérium et du tritium,
ça fait de l’hélium !
Ce faisant, notre siamois perd un neutron au passage.
Abonnez vous.
Et ça c’est youpi puisque ce neutron est transformé en énergie.
Et c'est cette énergie de fusion
qu'on projette d'utiliser pour produire de l'électricité.
C'est beaucoup plus safe qu'un réacteur à fission
puisque d’après les lois de la physique,
la réaction tend à s’arrêter d’elle-même.
En temps normal, les Dupond.t n’entrent pas en collision,
ils se repoussent constamment.
Il faut vraiment des conditions très particulières pour qu’ils fusionnent.
Si jamais y’a un bin’s, on arrête tout
et notre tas d’atomes se refroidit en quelques secondes
et devient quasiment inoffensif.
Il n'y a pas à évacuer de chaleur résiduelle contrairement à la fission.
Donc pas de Fukushima 2.0 en vue.
Et puis c'est aussi un peu classe parce que c'est le même
genre de réaction qui se produit au cœur des étoiles, et notamment dans notre soleil.
Les Bretons, vous devrez me croire sur parole,
mais oui, le soleil existe vraiment, c'est pas un mythe.
Et donc, le but de l'expérience géante devant laquelle je me trouve,
ce serait de montrer qu'on est
capables de fabriquer des réacteurs à fusion nucléaire.
Que c'est faisable à la fois scientifiquement et technologiquement.
Et si je vous en parle, ce n'est pas du tout parce qu'Iter nous a donné un pognon de dingue pour le faire
car, comme chacun sait, le Vortex est vendu
aux lobbies de big pharmonsantoareva.
Rassurez-vous : ça va pas m'empêcher de faire
toutes les mauvaises blagues qui me passeront par la tête,
le dernier qui m'a censurée n'est pas encore né.
Non, si je veux vous en parler ici,
c'est avant tout pour vous narrer en toute objectivité
la magnifique aventure humaine qu'est Iter et comment elle va sauver le monde.
Iter est à l’origine l’acronyme de International Thermonuclear Experimental Reactor.
Mais ça veut aussi dire en latin “le chemin”.
Et ils en ont parcouru du chemin,
ils ont tenu la distance, depuis le lancement du projet en 1985.
Annoncé pour... puis pour... puis pour...
Moi qui ai grandi pas loin,
je peux vous dire que c'était un peu notre Arlésienne ce projet.
Eh oui, je vous avais prévenus que je ne mâcherais pas mes mots.
Ni les grains de maïs.
Comme ça je les récupère intacts à la sortie et c'est reparti pour un tour.
C’était l’astuce écolo et économique du jour !
Aujourd'hui, Iter réunit 35 pays :
ceux de l’Union européenne, la Suisse, le Royaume Uni,
la Chine, l’Inde, le Japon, la Corée, la Russie et les Etats-Unis.
Bon, mais d'où qu’y vient, ce projet scientifique d'une ampleur
telle qu'on l'a comparé en toute modestie au programme Apollo ?
Eh bien je n'ai qu'un mot à dire : pavlova.
Non pardon, l'autre : perestroïka.
En pleine guerre froide, le padre russe Michael Gorbatchev
a cherché un projet scientifique à proposer
à la communauté internationale, dont Romuald Reagan,
pour travailler ensemble et ainsi œuvrer pour la paix.
Et, entre parenthèses,
c'est aussi dans cette optique que le Cern a créé le LHC sus-mentionné.
Vous verrez,
y'a pas mal de parallèles entre ces deux instruments scientifiques.
Car malgré les apparences, je ne vais pas complètement n'importe où.
Or donc, ce bon vieux Gorbatchev s'est dit "Oh ma caille”
Oui, dans ma tête
les Russes parlent toujours avec un accent marseillais.
“Oh ma caille, la fusion nucléaire c'est tarpin bien, salette.
Ni nous ni les ricains n’y arrivons,
alors unissons nos forces comme on unit les légumes du soleil dans une ratatouille.
Et puis y a pas d'applications militaires directes,
ça ne peut engendrer que
paix, amour, aïoli, cagoles et
énergie pour recharger ses enceintes bluetooth
et se déhancher sur le dernier best of des chœurs de l'Armée rouge."
C'est ainsi que naquit ce gros projet scientifique qui s'est bâti sous le chant des cigales.
D'où le retard de livraison. Bah oui, la sieste et tout,
faut pas déconner quoi.
Donc, on l'a vu tout à l'heure, la fusion,
en théorie c'est simple comme Bon Jovi.
Vous prenez Dupont D et Dupont T,
vous les cognez jusqu'à temps qu'ils fusionnent et paf !
Vous voilà avec un Dupont He et un bras arraché qu'on convertit en énergie.
CQFD.
Mais en pratique, ça demande un certain doigté.
On a plusieurs façons d’y arriver mais ici,
on utilise un genre de donut géant.
Sauf que ce donut ne contient pas
une promesse de diabète de type 2, mais du vide !
Et c'est dans cette chambre à vide qu'on injecte un gaz de Dupond D à 150 millions de degrés.
Bah oui, on imite le soleil, faut s’en donner les moyens aussi.
Ce gaz ainsi chauffé va se transformer en plasma.
Vous savez, c'est le 4e état de la matière.
Chauffez du liquide, il devient gazeux.
Chauffez du gaz, il devient du plasma !
Chauffez du plasma, ben vous avez du plasma encore plus chaud.
Seulement, si on laisse ça comme ça,
notre soupe incandescente va simplement cramer les bords du donut
et se faire la malle, tel Carlos Ghosn quittant le Japon.
Il nous faut donc un moyen de confiner notre soupe
pour pas qu'elle s'échappe et aussi pour pas qu’elle refroidisse.
Et pour ça, on utilise, tenez-vous bien,
des aimants supraconducteurs.
Comme ceux du LHC, mais en encore plus grand.
Nom de Zeus !
Grâce à ces aimants, on va générer
plusieurs champs électromagnétiques pour retenir le plasma.
Car vois-tu, Marty,
à ces températures extrêmes les particules du plasma prennent tellement cher
qu'elles perdent des bouts d'elles-mêmes au passage,
des électrons,
ce qui fait qu'elles deviennent électriquement chargées.
Donc elles se mettent à réagir au champ électromagnétique.
Et c’est ça qu’on va utiliser pour les maintenir en place,
un peu comme un chien de berger arrive à contenir un troupeau de brebis.
A partir de là, on balance dans notre plasma de Dupond D
des glaçons de Dupond D et T,
comme dans une anisade à savourer à la fraîche
après une bonne partie de pétanque.
C'est là que notre pastis nucléaire se trouble :
nos Dupond D et T fusionnent et émettent des neutrons,
qui vont bombarder les parois de la chambre à vide.
Eh oui, puisque les neutrons sont aussi neutres que la Suisse,
le champ électromagnétique n’a pas d’effet sur eux.
Ils peuvent donc s’échapper pépouse.
Et c'est donc l'énergie de ces neutrons qu'on va récupérer
en sortie de ce donut géant
qu'on appelle poétiquement un tokamak.
C'est l'acronyme des termes russes
« toroïdalnaïa kameras magnitnymi katushkami »,
que l'on peut traduire comme chacun sait par
"chambre toroïdale avec bobines magnétiques".
C'est trivial.
Notre tomacaque va fonctionner en quelque sorte par à-coups.
C’est-à-dire que chaque décharge va durer quelques centaines de secondes,
puis on laisse notre mini-soleil se refroidir pendant une centaine de secondes,
et hop c’est reparti pour un tour.
Des takhotakhs, euh tokamaks, on en a déjà construit 250 sur Terre.
Mais celui d'Iter est le plus gros.
Mes confrères journalistes vont être aux anges :
le complexe tokamak fait la superficie d’un terrain de foot !
Rien que la chambre à vide mesure 1.600 m3,
donc on pourrait y coller
4.000 vessies humaines ou 32.000 prostates.
Ce qui va permettre de manipuler un plasma 10x plus volumineux
que celui du plus gros tokakam opérationnel aujourd'hui.
En 2020, les pièces ont commencé à arriver sur place.
Leur assemblage va durer 5 ans.
La date du premier plasma est fixée au mois de décembre 2025.
L’objectif, c’est non seulement de
produire de l’énergie grâce à ce plasma.
Parce qu’actuellement, dans les autres tokamakaks,
le plasma produit moins d’énergie qu’il n’en reçoit,
donc on perd de l’énergie au final.
Là,
non seulement l’idée serait d’en produire plus qu’il n’en consomme,
mais pas juste un peu plus :
on est sur un facteur 10.
C’est à dire qu’à terme, les Itériens aimeraient produire
500 MW de puissance de fusion à partir de
50 MW de puissance de chauffage.
Imaginez le nombre d'amplis qu'on pourrait alimenter avec ce courant.
Parfait pour le concert ultime de Jean-Michel Jarre
avec les hologrammes de Gorillaz, Hatsune Miku et Mélenchon.
Mais quel intérêt d'un réacteur à fusion
par rapport à nos bons vieux réacteurs à fission ?
Eh bien d'abord,
il n'y a pas de risque d'emballement, comme on l'a dit au début.
Mais c'est pas tout !
Déjà, à masse de combustible égale,
on produit plus d’énergie avec la fusion qu’avec d’autres sources.
4 fois plus qu’avec la fission et
quasi 4 millions de fois plus qu’en brûlant du charbon, du pétrole ou du gaz.
Ensuite, la fusion est une source d’énergie bas carbone.
Comme la fission, d’ailleurs.
Mais bon, tout n’est pas rose avec la fusion.
Parce que se pose la question des déchets nucléaires.
Du coup si c’est de la fusion nucléaire, il n’y a pas de déchets!
Alors, c’est plus compliqué que ça.
Tu l’as dit tout à l’heure,
le résultat de la fusion c’est l'hélium qui est un gaz non radioactif.
Mais il y aura quand même des déchets qu’il faudra gérer et stocker,
et ça on va les diviser en 3 types.
Le premier type c’est les déchets gazeux,
mais ça on devrait pas dépasser les 2,5 grammes par an.
Ensuite tu as les déchets qui sont liquides,
ui sont contaminés par le tritium,
donc par exemple l’eau qui est issue des systèmes de refroidissement.
Et le troisième type de déchet c’est les poussières qu’on va dire activées,
qui sont des poussières radioactives dûes
à la réaction des neutrons sur les parois de la chambre à vide.
Du coup il y a des déchets,
mais c’est pas des déchets de haute activité à vie longue comme avec la fission, c’est ça?
Oui c’est ça,
en fait c’est des radio éléments qui ont une demi-vie que d’une dizaine d’années.
Et ça c’est cool,
parce que du coup on va pouvoir gérer et stocker tous ces éléments
dans une installation qui s'appellera sûrement “INTERMED”
on sait pas encore où ça se situera mais normalement ça se passera là-bas.
Et du coup ces éléments qui ne sont pas à haute activitée à vie longue,
en fait au bout de 100 ans ils seront quasiment plus radioactifs voire plus du tout,
et du coup par la suite on pourra les recycler.
Ok
Bon, c’est bien mignon tout ça,
mais vous me connaissez, j’allais pas m’arrêter en si bon chemin.
C’est l’heure d’attaquer le croustillant.
Car oui, comme toute installation nucléaire,
Iter comprend des risques, il peut y avoir des accidents.
Et c’est l’IRSN, l’institut de radioprotection et de sûreté nucléaire, un établissement public,
qui a été chargé de les évaluer, ces risques.
Et y’en a quelques-uns.
D’abord,
le risque d’exposition aux rayonnements ionisants des travailleurs.
Ben oui,
si vous bossez dans une centrale nucléaire,
vous êtes plus exposé à la radioactivité
qu’un babos dans sa yourte qui squatte un champ dans la Creuse.
Mais bien évidemment, ce risque d’exposition est réduit au minimum :
personne n’est au contact direct de la machine,
la maintenance est entièrement robotisée.
Iter vise une dose individuelle de 10 mSv/an au max.
En passant, c’est deux fois moins que
la limite réglementaire d’exposition des travailleurs du nucléaire en France...
Le point un peu plus physique, c’est le risque de disruption du plasma.
Car voyez-vous, le plasma est un animal difficile à amadouer.
Parfois, il décide d’installer un babyfoot dans ses locaux,
embauche un chief happiness manager
et lance sa gamme d’enrouleurs électriques de PQ
u’il promeut grâce à des influenceurs.
En un mot comme en cent, il disrupte.
Un peu comme un éternuement XXL
de truc extrêmement chaud au beau milieu de notre chambre à vide.
Pas glop.
Si le plasma parvient à
entrer en contact avec la paroi interne de la chambre à vide,
il n’est plus électromagnétiquement confiné du tout.
Il s’échappe.
Ca peut notamment causer des chocs thermiques ou
des courants de Foucault.
Les courants de Foucault c’est un phénomène physique
qui donne une envie irrépressible de gagner des millions.
Bref, ça beugne la machine (l’était impeccab)
en risquant des fuites du liquide de refroidissement et en l’érodant prématurément.
C’est pas de la fiction, pour le coup.
Les instabilités du plasma c’est un problème fréquent dans les tomamaks du monde entier.
Mais le danger c’est d’abîmer la machine,
c’est tout, donc ça craint rien pour les populations.
Dernier point, les risques sismiques.
Je ne résiste pas à l’appel de la géologie.
Figurez-vous que le site d’Iter est construit à proximité d’une faille active !
C’est plutôt cocasse, non ?
D’autant plus que ça tremble pas mal dans la région.
En témoigne le plus gros séisme du coin qui remonte à l’été 1708,
à Manosque.
Aucun bâtiment ne s’en est tiré sans égratignures,
plus d’une centaine de maisons ont été transformées en tas de cailloux.
Alertée par les secousses, toute la population a déserté le village.
On raconte même qu’un paralysé, abandonné dans son lit d’hôpital,
a miraculeusement recouvré l’usage de ses jambes
et s’est fait la malle avec les autres.
Un auteur a aussi rapporté que, je cite,
“dans cette fuite précipitée, on vit des femmes honnêtes et des filles sages,
surprises dans un déshabillé plus que négligé,"
"se sauver dans cet état et paraître en public à demi nues
sans s’apercevoir de l’indécence de leur habillement”.
Donc même quand elles s’escampent d’un tremblement de terre dévastateur,
on juge encore les filles sur leur tenue.
Vivement l’émission Les reines du shopping spéciale
“je fuis l’Afghanistan”.
Mais je divague.
Vague.
Imaginez la même chose demain, quand Iter sera en activité !
Les séismes, hein,
pas le sexisme ordinaire.
Et figurez-vous que les institutions qui bossent là-dessus
utilisent justement ce tremblement de Manosque comme référence.
Iter est construite de telle sorte à résister à un séisme d’une amplitude 40 fois pire,
donc qui libèrerait 250 fois plus d’énergie.
Au cas où.
Et ça, ça passe par
beaucoup d’études de terrain pour mieux connaître la faille et son activité,
merci les géologues,
et des truchements parasismiques pour
réduire la vulnérabilité des installations aux crises de Parkinson de la Terre.
Par exemple,
le tomakak est construit en béton spécialement renforcé
et s'appuiera sur des plots-supports,
ou piliers, conçus pour résister aux séismes.
Alors ça y est,
demain on pourra repasser ses culottes grâce à la fusion nucléaire ?
C’est la solution ultime à la transition énergétique,
pour un demain plus vert,
plus vertueux...
plus verticille,
plus vert-de-gris...
plus vermifugé?
Eh bah.
Eh bah..
Eh bah…
C'est plus compliqué que ça.
C’est le moment de dégainer ma carte économie.
Donc je me posais une question,
imaginons que la fusion ça marche pour faire de l’énergie pas cher demain,
est ce que pour autant ça nous sauve la vie?
Alors.
Evidemment t’as tout un délire sur:
d’accord t’as inventé la fusion mais alors après il faut tout installer etc…
Quand est ce que vraiment t’as suffisamment d’énergie pour…
Mais admettons t’as un autre problème,
qui est un problème économique et stratégique.
Tout ce qui produit du pétrole dans le monde,
t’as des entreprises privées
mais t’as aussi beaucoup d’entreprises qui sont détenues par des états
donc tu peux vraiment parler de pays producteurs de pétrole.
Ces pays producteurs de pétrole
on leur en demande toujours plus tous les ans,
malgré le fait qu’on est supposés faire la transition énergétique et tout,
ils baissent pas particulièrement leur production.
Donc eux ils sont contents ils continuent de vendre leur pétrole.
Si demain t’as une technologie qui vient concurrencer ça,
et où on vient leur dire:
“Ah bah finalement on a besoin de moins en moins de votre pétrole”
bah eux ça leur fait
de moins en moins de sous pour financer leur niveau de vie.
Donc tu peux penser que eux vont réagir en disant:
“Ah mais attendez nous on peut
baisser le prix de notre baril de pétrole"
"pour concurrencer le prix de votre nouvelle technologie.”
Donc en fait t’as beau avoir la fusion t’as pas forcément résolu le problème.
C’est plus large que ça.
T’as une dimension géopolitique, économique,
dont il faut tenir compte.
Et je voulais te poser une question,
parce que ça c'est quand même une technologie qui va se mettre en place à long terme.
Qui est ce qui pourrait être susceptible de financer des trucs pareils?
Bah, c’est une autre question effectivement.
Ce qu’on constate aujourd’hui c’est que de plus en plus le secteur privé
veut financer des choses qui sont rentables à court terme,
à relativement court terme.
Or, pour des technologies comme ça
c’est possible que ça coûte très très cher à mettre en place au début
et que donc ta rentabilité elle intervienne que dans 20 ans, 30 ans, 40 ans…
et c’est pas sûr que le secteur privé veuille financer ce genre de choses.
Iter moi de ce que j’ai compris,
c’est juste un labo, c’est un test,
et donc effectivement on teste la technologie avec des fonds publics.
Une fois que mettons que là ça fonctionne
et que derrière tu puisses construire une vraie centrale qui produit de l'électricité,
la question qui se pose c’est:
ok c’est quoi le modèle économique de ce truc là?
Est ce qu’on demande au secteur privé d'investir?
Et du coup le secteur privé il va demander une certaine rentabilité,
du coup ça donne quoi comme prix de l'électricité?
Tu vois ça pose plein d’autres problèmes.
C’est pas que une histoire de on trouve la bonne technologie
et puis c’est bon on a résolu le problème.
Ouais, c'est plus compliqué que ça quoi.
En bref,
la fusion n’est pas la solution miracle pour une transition énergétique smooth,
car cela arrivera trop tard pour faire face au réchauffement climatique.
On est encore très loin d'un vrai réacteur destiné à produire de l'électricité.
Iter n'est jamais qu'une machine expérimentale, comme le LHC finalement.
Pour l’instant on en est à la première étape : vérifier la faisabilité de la chose.
Et quand ce sera vérifié,
si c’est vérifié,
l faudra encore construire deux autres centrales.
DEMO d'abord, dans les années 50,
dans laquelle l'énergie produite sera récupérée sous forme d’électricité.
Mais en plus,
les chercheurs vont essayer de faire en sorte que le réacteur produise son propre combustible,
vous savez, le tritium.
Parce qu'à Iter, ils vont aller acheter
leurs quelques kilogrammes d’hydrogène radioactif en magasin spécialisé.
Pour DEMO,
l’idée consiste à ajouter du lithium dans des modules fixés à la chambre à vide.
Quand les neutrons issus de la fusion vont être catapultés sur ce lithium,
ça va lui fissionner la mouille pour donner
de l’hélium d’une part et du tritium.
*Voix aigüe*
Décidément, il est partout ! Habile Bill !
Et après Iter et Demo,
il sera venu le temps des rires et des chants et aussi de Proto,
le prototype industriel de centrale à fusion.
Ouf !
C'est bon, on y est ce coup-là.
Preuve donc
qu’on ne peut pas compter sur la fusion pour la transition énergétique,
on est sur des échelles de temps incompatibles.
C’est maintenant qu’il faut utiliser des sources d’énergie moins carbonées,
pas dans un siècle ou deux.
Mais il n’empêche que si tout marche,
vos arrière-petits-enfants pourront peut-être recharger leur voiture volante
grâce à la constellation de mini soleils qui ornera nos campagnes,
entre deux yourtes de cyberpunks à chiens.
Et du coup là on est entrés dans
le bâtiment administratif et je te jure mais tout était flambant neuf!
C’était incroyable
j’avais jamais vu une moquette aussi douce.
Et je te jure, les portes d’entrées!
T’arrives,
elles s’ouvrent toutes seules devant toi…
Mais c’est han!
C’est incroyable, franchement on arrête pas le progrès,
c’est dingue!
Ils sont  passés où les autres là?
Ils sont partis faire du camping
Quoi? Enfin qui?
Eh ben… Mehdi et Clara, au moins…
et puis Lê.
Du coup j’imagine qu’il y a Fred aussi vu qu’ils sont tout le temps ensemble.
Ah bah super quoi, je reviens et tout le monde s’est barré…
Bah on est là nous hein.
Ouais enfin bon, le prenez pas mal...
Ils auraient pu me demander quand même…
T’inquiète Valentine, moi j’ai passé une super journée.
Je resterai avec toi quoiqu’il arrive.
Toi et moi, c’est à la vie et à la mort.
*respire fort*
*Voix aigüe* Ca na vraiment plus aucun sens *rires*
*chanson* Y.M.C.A.
Do you prefer this style or this style?
Vous avez vu?
Il y a des numéros sur ces bâtiments, ils sont rangés par ordre. Coïncidence?